foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the Tom Clancy games date back to 1996
when the man himself co-founded the
video game development Studio Red Storm
entertainment
later on Ubisoft would purchase Red
Storm and acquired the Perpetual rights
to use Clancy's name and work for video
games and related media
at that time all games were connected to
the same universe
over the last couple of decades some of
the original games have stayed True to
this but there have been many later
editions that have certainly moved in a
different direction
in this video I would like to quickly
run through the Tom Clancy games that
have been released and how they fit into
the overall clancyverse timeline
I won't be talking about every game like
politica this is some very early work
and there isn't a huge amount of
information on it
I also won't be going through every
single crossover and mention across the
games just the main crossover points
because there is an absolute heap of
them a lot quite small and insignificant
but they're also quite a number that
were very obviously just for promotional
purposes rather than being part of the
overall story and the Tom Clancy
universe
the Tom Clancy names and series I'll be
talking about are Rainbow Six Ghost
Recon
Splinter Cell indoor Hawks the division
Elite Squad and X defiant
the dates these games were produced and
worked on are as shown Rambo 6 1998 to
present Ghost Recon 2001 to present
Splinter Cell 2002-2013.
end War
2008-2014 Hawks 2009-2010
the division 2016 to present Elite Squad
2020-2021 in X defiant still to be
released
but this isn't particularly useful when
talking about how they cross over in the
overall universe so let's show them on
the same graph based on the in-game
story years
now this needs to be taken very Loosely
any game still being worked on don't
really have an end date yet so I've just
run them off the edge of the chart for
now
but also there's nothing to say that
some of these other games no longer
being made won't be featured later on
like we've seen with Splinter Cell
as you can see Elite Squad and X defiant
don't actually have a timeline and to be
fair they really couldn't have one they
feature a number of characters and
factions that just couldn't coexist at
the same time
these two titles are very obviously
separate from the main Universe while
using the Tom Clancy name and characters
purely for marketing purposes
in 1996 we're introduced to Rainbow
which is a newly created multinational
counter-terrorism unit composed of elite
soldiers from NATO countries formed to
address the growing problem of
international terrorism
the Rainbow Six story ran for eight
years before the next game storyline
came into the picture
in 2004 Sam Fisher a covert Ops veteran
is recruited to spearhead the newly
activated Splinter Cell program which is
a part of the Third Echelon a top secret
initiative within the National Security
Agency
four years later we were introduced to
the newly conceived Squad of the United
States Special Operations forces
referred to as ghosts
Ghost Recon begins its story in 2008
following the civil unrest in Russia
that has come to be from an ultra
nationalist regime being placed into
power
in 2014 we are given the role of a U.S
Air Force pilot and Squadron leader of
an elite unit called Hawks or high
altitude Warfare experimental Squadron
from the very beginning we are tasked
with providing esport for a ghost recon
team carrying out missions in Mexico
over the next six years Hawks and the
ghosts would carry out many operations
together
there are also brief references towards
Rainbow Six and and War dotted
throughout
in 2015 a biological attack in New York
takes down the city and brings the
entire United States government to the
brink of collapse
a group of Sleeper Cell agents called
the division are then activated as the
country's last line of defense as all
other conventional means have failed
this pandemic affected not just the us
but the entire planet
however there is no mention of this
potential Extinction event in any of the
Rainbow Six Ghost Recon or Hawk stories
that were playing out during the same
time
it was confirmed by developers but
before and during the development that
the division universe is separate from
other Tom Clancy games
peace between the global superpowers of
the United States European Federation
and Russia is balancing on a knife's
edge due to the worldwide energy crisis
and the shifting of the balance of power
by 2020 World War III erupts affecting
every continent on the planet
while end War heavily features units and
characters from Ghost Recon Hawks
Rainbow Six and Splinter Cell its story
is inconsistent with the other titles
for example Hawks and the Ghost Recon
Future Soldier Story continues on
through 2020 and Beyond and have clearly
not been affected in any way by an event
such as a worldwide war
while obviously linked in some way and
War appears to be more of an alternative
future to the Tom Clancy Universe
timeline that the other games are
running along
in 2019 during operation Watchmen
Splinter cells Sam Fisher has been
deployed into Bolivia in order to
recover sensitive intelligence data from
a rogue CIA officer
the fourth Echelon get in contact with
Karen Bowman and borrow the ghost team
to assist in this mission
later on while still in Bolivia the
ghosts are investigating a mesca of
cartel members when they learn of
rainbow operative kavira and that she
has gone AWOL killing Santa Blanca gang
members
as part of operation Archangel Nomad and
the ghosts assist team rainbow with
locating her
in 2020 an experienced an aging Sam
Fisher is brought on board with Team
rainbow adopting the code name zero
he would later become the first member
of the rainbow operation staff division
as an instructor for the program
in 2025 Sam Fisher would next be seen
arriving on the island of arroa
he is on the hunt for a man known only
as the strategist
with help from the ghosts they track him
down
shortly after the ghost would be visited
by another familiar group
Rambo had learned of a PMC located on
naroa who were producing a nerve gas
agent with the intention of selling it
overseas to foreign militaries and
terrorist groups
as part of operation Amber Sky the
ghosts and rainbow would hunt down those
involved and put a stop to the
production
as I stated earlier on this wasn't
intended to talk through the overall
story of the Clancy verse just how each
of these games have been connected over
the years
because I like to write up a lot of
speculation videos I see a lot of
comments around other Tom Clancy titles
and how these could have been evolved
so I wanted to quickly put this together
to help clear a few things up
it really must be noted that this is
purely based on the state of these games
as of writing the script recent years
have proven that writers under the
Clancy name have been allowed to be a
little bit more relaxed with how they
tackle things
plus I've noticed over the years certain
dates in the timeline have been changed
or removed altogether
so it's entirely possible that certain
games and events that previously didn't
make sense could suddenly be possible in
the same timeline
summing up at this stage Rainbow Six
Ghost Recon Splinter Cell and Hawks all
run on the same timeline and are a part
of the main Clancy universe
end War although following a similar
history is more of an alternative future
to what is playing out in the main story
had it been more commercially successful
back when it was released it could be a
different story today
the division so far has been confirmed
as its own universe and the likes of
Elite Squad and X defiant don't really
seem to have any supporting story that
would make sense
this has been another one of those
videos that I really only decided to put
together at the last minute while I was
researching for other topics
I'm curious about all of you watching
this who have made it this far how far
back did you start playing Tom Clancy
games let me know in the comments
otherwise thank you very much for
watching hopefully you found some of
this interesting and I'll catch you in
the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]